Hello everybody! [Closed Captions provided by Captain Cool, and others as well! Now including a new face!]
My name is Markiplier and welcome to INSIDE.
Now, I know you guys have been asking for this game for a long time
and I'm sorry for the delay
I meant to get to it sooner...
But I just got so busy
And in fact,
I'm prepping for Comic-Con right now,
which means that I'm gonna go meet you guys-
If anyone's going to San Diego, say hi to me!
I'm gonna be at the Red Giant booth while I'm there.
Um, but also,
I tried to start...
...recording this just a little bit ago,
and this is going to be really disgusting
and probably doesn't speak well to my
hygiene and how I take care of everything in my room--
--please don't judge me!
--There's something about the...
...the color scheme?
Oh, by the way, this is very nice--
there's so many nuanced animations in this game
that I absolutely love, but--
I'll get to the game in a second, I gotta talk about this horrifying thing!
The--
--color scheme made this glare appear on my monitor
and...
made me finally notice...
all the spit
that has been collecting on my monitor
over the years,
and there's no easy way to say it,
I had to stop recording and clean it up!
So I'm sorry!
and this is totally not to do with the game,
it's just the reality of my life right now
and
this is about as far as I got
when I've started playing it before.
So,
This...
Is...
made by the same people-
Bye, truck!
I actually don't know why you're leaving...
Or where I am.
Oh!
There's a guy in the background.
Hello!
Am I supposed to do something about that?
Is that good or bad?
Okay.
So,
This is made by the same people that made LIMBO
and if you remember LIMBO,
LIMBO actually came out about the
time when I was first starting to do YouTube.
Maybe even before that,
I can't remember the actual date.
But it's one of the earliest ''Let's Play''s I ever did.
And LIMBO...
Always will hold a special place in my heart,
because LIMBO-
Hello...
Was-
Guh.
HI.
What happens if I step out in front?
Hello!
Hi!
Oh. Ho.
HEY. HEY.
STRANGER DANGER!
AHH!
Oh God!
Oh.
Okay?
Well, that's no good!
I don't even know why I'm hiding-
I don't know why they would be looking for me
and what was with his mask?
That's so weird!
Ah, it's so cool!
Ah, it's fascinating.
It's fascinating because there's a lot of,
like I said,
nuanced animation that's going on in the background
and it's really cool to see because
it's not emphasized.
And this is in the same way that LIMBO was.
There's a lot of stuff happening in the environment
and the world-
Even though it's like a 2D, side-scrolling deal-
Like, the world is alive! And it felt alive-
And in LIMBO,
it was a horrifying shadow world
that consumed children and
killed everybody around you!
And had horrifying monsters-
I guess it's okay to go now.
What is that?
Oh, what is that?
It's like some sort of power-doohickey.
Ooh.
It's so weird looking into the distance and seeing the shadows of the trees.
Really gives a size to the forest.
OH, YEAH,
and LIMBO had the things going in the foreground sometimes!
Aw, it's so cool!
BYE!
Is this important?
Oof.
I can yump.
I CAN YUMP!
Aw, I remember the 'YUMP'ing and the 'BOOSH'ing!
Oh, it came from LIMBO!
And also!
Woah, what was that?
Wait, I-
I did something with it!
Did I do something or is that just my imagination?
Eh.
Oh.
Wow.
I just slapped my face across it.
Eh.
EHH.
Okay.
So can I PUSH this?
CAN I BOOSH THIS?
PLEASE?
Aw, no!
I thought I could boosh it up to the wall
and then jump over!
Oh, there's a doggy over there.
Oh, what a good pup!
Who's a good pup over there?
I'll be with you in a moment!
I gotta find a way around-
Do I have a 'use' button?
ah
I'm not a hundred percent certain
but maybe there's something backtrack that I could possibly do...
Now I don't know anything about this game,
other than, like,
everyone said that it's a phenomenal successor to LIMBO...
Uh.
I don't know how closely it relates
or if at all-
I am not a hundred percent sure that it does-
Oh!
Ah, well,
I'm a hundred percent wrong and I'm already lost!
I just started this game.
But when I say...
That, uh, my-
It was like-
"Baby Markiplier's First Edit"
was me
making my webcam black and white,
but it only took me 'til the third episode to figure out that I needed to do that.
But it was fascinating to SEE...
Because...
It was like the first moment where I realized,
'Oh my God.'
'My editing influences the experience that you guys have
in this game!'
And the reason I made it black and white, 'cause the whole
game's black and white.
Okay, I-
I-
I SEE THE PUZZLE PIECES.
I JUST GOTTA SLOT 'EM TOGETHER!
How the frick do I...
EUAhHh
Oh-
Ohh!
CTRL!
OHHH,
okay!
I didn't know that!
Okay.
There was no-
There was no 'CTRL' instruction manual, so
I-I-I-
I didn't know that was something that I needed to do.
Okay.
HABOOM!
I BOOSH-DED!
I booshed it so good...
Hi doggy!
Are you gonna notice me?
You gonna come runnin' after me?
Huhuhu.
HUHUHU.
Man, that's so awesome!
The way it makes things theem disthant!
Sorry, speech impediment-
Eugh.
Anyway.
It's just,
the depth of the world is very fascinating.
And
I
might've said it
but I'm not a hundred percent sure why this child-
Is running away.
Hello?
Okay?
YUMP.
No?
Boosh?
Oh, something's going on over there-
Maybe I gotta make a running jump for it.
Let's give it a go!
HABOOSKI!
Nope, that ain't it.
Okay, so if that's not it
then I gotta find another way...
'Cause I don't think I can make that jump
and I don't th-
Oh, maybe this box?
Maybe I can PYULL IT-
I CAN PULL IT!
O'M GONNA PULL DE BOX.
Okay, get up-
No-
No, no-
Hey, hey, hey, hey-
I thought that box was gonna come crashing down on me!
HABOOSHKI!
HEBOOSKI!
There we go!
And away we go!
HELLO.
NYEHEHEHEH.
Okay.
Time for swimming.
Hi! Can you see me?
Oh, maybe I'm escaping-
Oogh-
Well, that doesn't sound good!
Euh-
AH, AHHHh!
AGHH, ITS NOT GOOD!
AUGH, PUPPY!
DON'T DO ANYTHING!
Oh God!
That's not good!
What happens if the puppy gets me-
AHH.
OHHohoH GOD!
OHhOhHo GOD.
OhhOHho no!
Ohhhohohohohohohohohohohoho.
I mean, I don't know why I expected anything else!
Oh God.
Ohoho God.
EUh,
so scary!
That puppy
is so angry!
EUAahH!
Okay, quick thinking!
HABAHHHH!
Ah, I got it!
Haha, ha!
HA, HA, HA, HA.
Serves you right for trying to murder-lize me!
Well,
I don't think there's anything left for me here.
So I might as well just keep moving forward
and forget about trying to find all the deaths...
'Cause I mean, that-
That-
That was a thing about the original LIMBO, was-
There were so many ways to die...
There was just kinda fascinating to find them all, like, just like-
It was an experience just to go through the world
and die in super horrible ways...
Which is something that
I was very good at doing, if I remember properly!
I gotta go back and watch that.
Pro-
I probably will while I'm in San Diego just going back.
Not that I'm so narcissistic that I watch my old videos,
all the time but, I do go back every once in a while,
to experience memories and get some-
*Mumbling*
*louder mumbling*
*more mumbling*
*more louder mumbling*
Hahaha,
I knew what to do,
I figured it out, I used my huMAN brain
Okay, but you shall not find me
I mean, he'll probably kill me a whole bunch of times in the future,
but for now, faceless Chad over here,
is gonna go meandering to success.
Unless the internet has already given this kid a name,
in that case, it's whatever name that you have chosen,
this kid's name to be if he doesn't have a name for himself.
Hello.
Uh,
What's going on here?
Hello.
Someone hopped outta there,
and they're oddly...mumble...
gonna see me if I cross the front of their liiightsss.
So, what does that mean for meeee?
I don't know but everyone better quiet.
*sharp inhale*...That ain't good
HEY...HEY...STRANGER DANGER!!!
STRANGER DANGER!!! JUMP
ok stranger danger uahh!
That's right!
Ooooh, that ain't good
uh, oh
HII!!!
AAGGGHH!!!
OH, GOD!!!
Oooohhh...
Why was that necessary?!?
That seemed absolutely unnecessary.
Was I supposed to
go in the minivan or something
Ok, probably.
*Mark makes odd noise*
Okay so there's gotta be
There's gotta be...
*Mark makes another random noise*
Okay so there's gotta be
something to do with this minivan
I-I would imagine
hyup!
Uh oh
Oh Ah! Ahh! No! Oh god, oh geez...
Oh geez. Oh geez. Oh Ugh.
Ohohohohoho.
Oh no..
Oh this poor kid, this poor kid has ME
to control him
That ain't good
I mean I yumped,
I yumped to get away from the branch
And I know this should be a much more fluid experience for you guys,
but, I'm just as panicked as you are!
I'm just as terrible as horrible as you!
Ah! Don't do it.
Yeah I yumped! You guys can't yump as good as I'm jumping! I'm a professional yumper!
hyablegh!
Ow. Ah!
Don't shoot me! Why would you do that?! Be nice! Be friendly!
Be kind, rewind!
Oh, this is a whole bunch of bad
*screams*
*dogs barking in game*
ok!
Sploosh!
Ohhhh.
*in some kind of accent* ve are undervater now?
Aw! It's like, out of this worrrrld!
Nice!
Oh man that's so cool
Oh did I drown? Ah shit! God damn it!
I was too focused on having fuuun!
*Mark makes silly blubbing noise*
Oh they'll never find me,
they'll never ever find me
never ever and now I get good breath.
HII!!
I'm running away from you! Have good day
huh whuh? I'll die later don't worry,
don't worry about me I couldn't possibly
survive in here. Is there anything
underwater than I need to know about?
'Cause in "Out of This World" there was
horrifying tentacle monsters from an
alien planet trying to kill you
uuuh...
Wow...
That ain't good...
that's the opposite of good. Sorry!
Don't know why I'm apologizing to a
couple of dead pigs but, Sorry! Sorry!
Oh man this is so cool.
Just the environments,
the environment, and I
actually like I I really do appreciate
you know some people would feel that
it's limited to go left to right but I
appreciate,
the fact that I don't have to...
like intensely ex- whoa! Intensely explore
the environment because this is
the type of environment
it's so detailed and it seems so big
that I would personally want to go
around and wander everywhere but it's
nice
because while it's kind of A to B thing
with puzzles in the middle,
it's good...
that... it keeps the flow of the
game moving forward. Sorry, I just...
Is that something I should worry about?!
ok... alright. Carrying on... Carrying on!
oh well this seems relatively alright so
what's all this then?
whose farm is this and what dystopian
future do we exist in
oh man, are all the animals- Oh god
they are. All the animals are dead which
probably means those-
Oh! Little animals!
Oh my god! Oh my god, are those- are those
little birds?! Oooh are those little chickadee
birds? Ohohoh oh my god they're so cute!
Oh! Oh there's so many of them
I have a bad feeling that they're
suddenly gonna turn farrell and start
eating me alive but oh well
oh my god there's so many! Hello! Hi!
Ohohoh come with me. Oh follow
your new mama
Okay is that a rope that I need? There we- Oh no, I'm sorry! I hope you do okay on
your own
Herr major her manner
Cameron erber her bigger lift
there we go ok ah i'm assuming the Flies
are a good thing and probably not to do
with any sort of
death happening I'll guard I'll pull
this lever that sounds like food
I like pulling levers nope and never on
this lever didn't want to be pulled
what about this crank can I yank this
crank no can I turn this work
no okay I got a feeling that there's
something to do with that but i'm not
100 percent sure
what it's waiting for
I would think that it presented me with
a cranky yank and I'm supposed to yank
the crank but that's what everyone would
think when their approach with the
situation like this
I know birdies maybe i need them I need
them of course of course I need them
oh of course come on do the thing
can you do the thing to be doing do that
oh it's only this control that does it
oh i thought it was a different control
okay see I was pressing the left control
but it's the right control that actually
needs to be the thing so that's good to
know
right now i can push this thing you
breathe
I did nothing I'm little birdies come
with me
I hope I don't have to feed into this
all day
this seems to be a convenient ramp for
small creatures to walk into and I don't
know if that's a good thing
but you know why is it making me do that
fun dip up
oh no oh no oh god oh no I know what it
means we didn't do
oh it's so mean
it's so mean
pop up haha oh they're alive
oh okay but you're gonna feed the head
don't know how did they survive that
oh man I thought they were going to be
turned into meat and it was just going
to be a spray of blood that before you
picked it because I him so happy
oh man i was so i'm pretty sure they
probably got everyone with that and they
did that intentionally
okay just so long as we're on the same
page and everything's doing fine i'll
jump into that
well pig carcasses
I don't like that all right what do we
got over here
do i need to go the other way probably
towards more pig carcasses which is
always a good thing
so it's either it's either these things
or do i need to push the cart we have
pig carcasses that would be the obvious
thing to do
so it's either hood whoa
you seeing what I'm seeing yeah well oh
well oh well oh there are worms are its
words oh god I'm so sorry my skin just
started crawling like you wouldn't
believe
oh god oh why worms
why so many worms worms
Oh horrible ok so that answers the
question that some horrible disease
going through here
an infection I don't know if it affects
the whole world but it's bad but i gotta
crawl under it now I can climb ok that
makes sense
booski look well the book that makes it
so much worse are all god it's so
obvious now
have they always been there yeah okay
okay
that better and okay all right
yeah hello
yep
okie dokie
damn it out and how are you still wash
it out
well that would hurt well sorry I didn't
mean to do that I meant to jump on you
for
ok so i guess i imagine i got to jump
off a shin
whoops
ok so i gotta get him to do something
else
oh all the word
oh the worm o4m did I help
okay come with me oh you poor animal
oh you poor animal bond bubble
whatever it wasn't it oh my god i just
noticed
Oh what's with them what's wrong with
them
try there's something been in my I like
an eyelash but what is wrong with them
oh my god
it's horrible
I don't like that ah war there
oh oh yeah oh alright then
Sorry Sorry
ok lifting left ok
how am I controlling you
how am i doing that whoa weird
oh that's weird
whoa we'll move
all right um are you free now
can you go is it actually day oh my head
is in it I thought I was just holding
onto the thing
Oh fascinating ok so you all go in there
be good
alright much I'm a drop i guess
there we go who oh that's so weird
this world is fascinating of this world
is delighted full
I'm very into this I'm not even being
sarcastic
I am so into this all very much
awww kid you're strag you're so Strang
oh and i love how fluid it is haha i
love how fluid it is aw man it looks so
Oh mm-hmm love it love it love about
this phenomenal
oh wow I haven't geeked out about a game
like this in a long time that's
disconcerting
why are they being loaded up is that
what I was trying to escape from what
was that what was that
what's in here who will give a boo that
better
that better have just been kelp or some debris or some sort who no wonder i'm
running away
oh my god so there's some dark
implication about everything that's been
going on here some bad stuffs hanging
around here
move all right let's do it
I pull you oh no but it's a catch-22
if one is the way that it was maybe I
got a boosh it
i'll boosh it if i push it all the way maybe
it's gonna go down a bit
yarp I booshed it good
coming up on the climby hyup okie ne
yeah man this kid's got some strength I
guess if he's going to be a survivor
he's got to be stra-ong
ok and I got it
get down ok hyup hyup HYUP AYYYUP
one more come on you got it you got it
buddy ok so now that we're here do we go
bashing through that window like
gangbusters BLAH
Wow sorry maybe I pick up this chair no
maybe I open the window like a civilized
person
yep that's that's what I do here I was gonna smash my skull against the
window and get shards of glass in my
eyes
whereas this guy was logical and smart
that's why he would survive a scenario
not me is I'm going to fall on me
sure sounds like it oh no apparently I'm
fine
I keep looking out for traps and i'm
pretty sure it's that's by design
because in the last game
there was were a lot of traps
oo hello ok so what happens if i go right
I probably die right I'll prolly die
this'll kill me
this'll prolly kill me ow ow
oh no yep that was bad
well I'm an idiot let's try that again
shall we
with a little less stupid I mean it's
still going to have a heaping helping of
stupid don't you worry about that any
markiplier let's play comes with a free
complimentary side of stupid but in this
one for this kid's sake just a little less
ahhh
ahh ok
so
yeah ah ok so i gotta boosh it in some
capacity to try to make something go whumpy
so if i can make something go whumpy ahh I can jump on that and that will be
good enough for blah that would be
good blah blah i'm just hippity
hopping all the way to the candy shop hyup
hyup speedrunners baby parkour
parkour
well okay and then hippity hop all the
way over here to the candy shop push this
over on the unsuspecting villain
hey birdies ahh never mind i don't want
to kill you h-blah AHH ow.  well that was dumb.
ow. I had a funny feeling that something
bad was gonna happen
okay so maybe I gotta run after I boosh it
ahh oh geez well that was almost certain
death
I'm pretty sure there's probably another
way that I could have gone about that
but it wouldn't have been nearly as fuuun
let's not think about the dangerous
let's think about the fuuuun cause remember
still a lot of stupid oh that's so cool
there's like dinaamic dinnaemic
dynamic animiniation dynamic
animations
it's cool it's awesome all right scibbidy scat - scat bap a doo
ow my ankles all right what do we got
here
hello whoa aah whoa that was handy
whatever that was I am really strong
considering I just rip- that off its
hinges
what's down here I don't wanna go over here
there's something down I saw a guy i
don't like it when I see people alright what have we got here
hello.. oohh
but I didn't mean to i just keep pulling
on random things
why can't you make me boosh i'm good at
booshin I ain't good at pullin god damn it
I didn't mean to I'm sorry I don't know
what I did but I did it
whoa did I see something oh no that's
like boxes
I thought I saw someone standing in the
darkness back there but apparently not
that would have been terrifying. it would have been horrifying
not that this game has been thoroughly
horrifying this entire time but not this
time
ooh hope that did something good is that
shadows I see on the other side over
there
well that's probably bad ha ha-Buuh okay
stick my head in here somehow I know how
to use this and somehow is able to hold me
up by my gosh darn head
whibbidy whabbidy whubbidy whabbidy whubbidy boink- aww I thought there
was going to be something going on there- ohhhh
ok
whibbidy whabbidy whubbidy whabbidy whibbidy whabbidy whubbidy ok so the problem is they're
not in sync
so we need to figure out a way to get
them in the right equidistance-el so
that they can go to where they need to
go
ok so it's gotta be something to do with
that lever right right
it's got to be something to do with the
lever so this lever
oh it's about good okay good enough i
almost chopped that guy right in half
but this oops but this is how it's done
probably He- bleuh! Ok
so if I -- I gotta move
let's see
ehh-de-de -- and then we come back in and
we're good
bada-bing bada-boom I know what I'm
doing it's not that difficult but at
least I did something up. Hu-bllpfftt. Ok now we
keep moving on bye thank you love you
I -- I don't know.  Woah
Woah
that's not good that's not good at all
that's probably and that's probably bad
if I had to guess what something is that's
definitely bad boy oh boy
ok yeah I don't like it I don't like it
no likey okay where am I going down here
oh it's just a surge of them whup I got
the pipe Mirror's Edge up in this bitch
you didn't hear a thing
don't look up here don't you dare don't
you look buddy
that's so weird I mean there's been a
lot of dystopian futures but I haven't
really see one where they start herding
oh people as cattle. Ehn ehhh. Felt like that
could almost fall over but I'm not a
hundred percent sure if that was the
case
yeah they keep moving okie dokie
yyuhh ahh ahh oh boy oh boy
ha bup oh I thought that was gonna fall
off too - well probably best to just keep
moving anyway because they probably
heard something about that and they're
gonna come after me very soon
man this kid is going places I don't
know why he doesn't just stop and hide
but that probably wouldn't help anybody
that probably is very bad
oh man why and this seems like a recent
thing I mean number one there's worms
everywhere which I have a funny feeling
they're infected by some sort of mind
control worms
hi oh man but another is just their
super bizarre everything that's going on
man kinda cool though
but either way that's all the time i got
for this episode I'm going to be playing
this every single day this week while I'm at
ComicCon so don't you worry about that
i'm gonna get to the end of this very soon so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video.  Bye-bye!
OH! Oh you missed me you dick!
HABOOS--- *scream skips like a broken record*